you know i'm a capitalist at heart
but i believe that that it comes with
responsibility like when we did in our
company
so i'm happy and i applaud a jeff bezos
that leaves
uh the company you know jp morgan
wherever he was he was working at
goldman sachs
and goes to his garage to sell books and
becomes a multi-billionaire
happy forum great that's america but
damn it man
don't do it at the expense of people
that can't live a dignified life
you know pay a wage with someone like my
dad and my mother came
and with minimum wage salary back then
they were able to save enough in three
years where we
got the down payment of a little house
you know
so in america today how how do we have
disparity how do we got
people dying unemployment is so huge and
the stock market going to the roof
so yeah the distinction in classes are
so big
that you know what you know what edge is
in same thing that happened in cuba
i told this to my dad i said dad you
hate communism
he says of course i said you know why i
said that because you
were part of that five percent
that owned 95 of the wealth so when you
have 95
of the people have nothing and here
comes a good talking guy
charismatic and he's going to make
everything equal
guess where they're going to go with
that guy and that's what we're going to
have here in america
that's what conservative i mean all
kinds are going to disappear why
because people are going hungry in our
country people can make it
when we work hurricanes people who say
look they're stupid why don't they
abandon their house
i said abandon their house said do you
realize that poor guy can't even
has never hasn't ever in his life put a
full tank of gas
he goes from paycheck to paycheck from
two dollars of gas to three thousand gas
where the hell is he gonna go how is he
gonna survive
you know like people today whoa you know
the health is more important than the
economist [ __ ]
yes human life is very very important
but you know what
the economy is the health of so many
freaking people
now i can go to quarantine for well we
were two months
dude i was in quantity for 10 years you
know you know three by eight
no sex well part of it no bourbon
you know no netflix so one thing to me
is nothing
but some people the single mom 40 of the
mothers raising
children by themselves what does
quantity do
kill them and i talked about i said look
why don't we talk about the seventy
thousand
good americans that die every year of a
drug overdose
right you know will the government
worried about it's interesting we can't
find money for things like that for
drug overdoses for things like education
but as soon as
something like chronovirus hits we find
trillions of dollars we print it we
print it like it's going out of style
right because we're not backed by gold
anymore i worked for the fertilizer bank
i was the youngest employee 17 17 years
old yeah i worked for them for three and
a half years
that's what put me to school so i know
the inner workings of the fed
and i know all of that the thing about
it is that
right now the disparity is so horrific
that's why you're gonna see people talk
about socialist uh congresswoman god
listen in 10 years in 10 years i promise
you
i promise you that's all going to be in
our country what is
so uh socialist social agenda well
without a doubt
but look in reality what's america
we're a socialist country 80 of our gdp
goes to social services
right you know so the thing about it is
when we have this disparity of wealth
and the richer are getting richer
and the poor are getting poorer and
people can't support their families
and people are hurting you know what's
going to happen
someone's going to come in and say hey
you know what we're going to take all
the money from the rich people
what do you think what do you think the
majority of people gonna say what do you
think the answer is
well the answer no number one a balanced
capitalism right
capitalism is the best formula why
because people are
incentivized to create right to work
harder right why should you and i make
the same one you don't want to work and
i want to work
right but it cannot be at the expense or
if i invest and i
i take the risk i risk my own capital to
buy machines or a factory i pay the
lease
yeah exactly so when you go ahead and
you get
all that tax break so that you can
invest in machinery
right and in people and you buy the
stock back well i'm happy because i'm a
big
apple stockholder so i was happy right
but you know what happens to the rest of
america nothing so they sit there
and it makes no difference to them right
and they're hurting and they're hurting
big time you gotta hear
and and uh drug overdose it's the same
thing with the war on drugs the biggest
joke in the world
i mean the biggest joke in the world we
spend billions of dollars
and i tell you i told this to a senator
not at all listen stop the [ __ ]
you're not going to eliminate the
cartels trust me
you kill one that's 10 worst ones that
him in line
is not going to as long as america
consume 85 percent of the narcotics in
the world
someone's going to supply it right
supply and demand now i know how to win
the war on drugs right
how another thing is because here's the
other thing so i say
we spend billions on the drug on war to
go out to 15 cocaine right it's less
than fifteen percent of your drug
overdose
cocaine is less than fifty percent
fifteen okay less than fifteen percent
why are we going after big pharma which
is sixty one percent right right right
guess who should who did not shut down
in the coronavirus
yeah big pharma twice the overdoses
we've had
i know this virus i know a lawyer from
around here who defended a colombian
ship captain
who was sentenced to
i want to say it was over 50 years for
pulling the ship into the port of tampa
with hundreds of kilos of cocaine
he defended this guy this guy the the
ship got ambushed
on the way from colombia to tampa by
pirates
they put the cocaine on the ship held
the gun to the captain's head said if
you don't
bring this in tampa i'm gonna kill you
and your whole family so
he ended up doing it and they ended up
just getting this guy
so what this guy my friend who's the
lawyer he said most of the people that
end up going to prison are just the
pawns of the operation
the big the big the head honchos that
are running this running the businesses
they're protected because either they're
paying people off or they're not put
they're not
out there getting caught by people
because they're just not in the line of
fire because they put the pawns
out there to smuggle the stuff and they
can get caught yeah and the thing about
look there's a lot of corruption right
yeah you know in america we go a lot in
south america we call across america we
call it lobbyists
but it's corruption and uh so you ask me
how do you win the war on drugs
right i call a five-prong approach
number one
when we went to colombia because
colombia when we started colombia did
not grow any drugs right
it was all peru and bolivia we bring it
to colombia we started to
uh to uh crystallize it into cocaine we
used to bring the paste
then we start crystal and then we start
to grow how well for i'll give one
perfect example so we went to the people
that grew bananas
and this is just numbers for example so
i said how much you get paid per acre
well we get paid ten dollars and at the
end of the season
uh the big international banana
companies come and say well we don't
need no more bananas
he said well we don't even have roads to
take it to the city and sell the rest we
got to burn it
and we we don't have enough money to
make it through a year so here i come
the big bad drug lord right
and i said hey buddy forget about that
now i'll give you a thousand dollars
now that man is a very religious
anti-drug enter everything i said i'm
gonna give you a thousand dollars to
grow
cocaine what do you think he's gonna
think about the morality of cocaine
or he's gonna think about feeding his
family exactly so multi international
quit exploiting
south american uh growers and farmers
and then you will see
you will see what will happen that's
number one number two
and it's not that i'm against law
enforcement listen uh when when the
government when the president was
attacking the fbi
i defended the fbi there's bad people
everywhere
but there's a lot of good people in law
enforcement that go out
every day and might not see their family
so that they can go ahead and protect
you and i right
sure i was never able to buy an fbi
agent i was never ever
able to buy a dea agent and and we
bought in 1977 we're spending 100
we're spending a million dollars a month
in corruption
a million the math today where did that
money go paying people
paying judges politicians politicians
paying everybody that would take a
payoff
and it was easy for the fbi and dea
because
oh we would have paid him thousands of
dollars just to tell us
who's under investigation or not right
not to blow a case
so we didn't now yeah so there's my
there might be some bad fbi agent
hell yeah the bad api agent but i'm
gonna tell you as a whole it's a damn
good agency so
the d.a no informant as a whole is a
good
agency that guy that demonic guy that
killed that african-american man
yeah you can't throw all the people in
the world all the good officers
that risk their lives okay now
is there police abuse of course there's
police abuse there's humanity abuse
it isn't a badge it's people people are
are evil their people are evil deranged
mentally
but there's a lot of good people a lot
of good people
that leave their house every day so you
and i are safe right right
so that's the so that's number one so
number two
you go to stop dealing with that uh
multi international doing that and
number two you come
to united states and you take a lot of
this money that you're spending
in in in interdiction and fighting the
cartels i'm not saying you stop
uh law enforcement you start you go on
but you don't need a hundred thousand
agents that ain't doing crap
you're confiscating very little and then
you invest
in the communities you invest in in
non-for-profits that are working their
ass off and they can turn communities
around
i can tell you two perfect examples of
what can be done to change those
communities and then you
you spend money in mental health because
a lot of the addicts
are only addicts because the mental
health problem in america is enormous
and people just don't want to deal with
it
so you invest in the people where you
attack all of a sudden
not the not the supply you attack the
demand
see nixon had it right nixon when he
started uh the war on drugs the first
president
he went after the to help the addicts he
created the methadone clinics in new
york
for the heroin and he cleaned up new
york reagan came in
and said i'm a tough cowboy [ __ ] i'm
going to go after
the uh suppliers and then we were so
happy
i it was in the midst of my reign i was
so happy because number one
i don't even say come after me early on
you're not gonna get me that's number
one
and number two just don't mess with my
demand
[Laughter]